disclaimer this is about to get romantic
as Africa what's up friends its Pride
Month and one of the strongest forms of
expression and education for the
movements through the years has been
cinema so we're gonna take a look at
five essential LGBTQ films right now on
the ketchup all of this month and beyond
be sure to go to Rotten Tomatoes comm
and check out our rainbow tomatoes hub
which has all kinds of lists including
LGBTQ TV series horror films
documentaries and more plus our ranking
of the 200 best LGBTQ movies of all time
and we're gonna take a look at a handful
from that list right now starting with
one at the very top 2016 certified fresh
moonlight directed by Barry Jenkins this
film tells the heartbreaking story of a
young black man who grapples with his
identity and sexuality told across three
defining chapters in his life with
critics calling it a remarkable and
brilliantly crafted look at lives too
rarely seen in cinema moonlight is the
first LGBTQ and the first film featuring
an all-black cast to win the Academy
Award for Best Picture it also won four
adapted screenplay and Mahesh lolly
picked up a Best Supporting Actor Oscar
for his performance as well moving down
the list we find a 2018 Chilean film a
fantastic woman which is certified
fresh' at 94% this one is about a
transgender nightclub singer who comes
under suspicion when her much-older
lover dies and it became the first movie
led by a transgender character and actor
to win an Oscar for Best Foreign
Language feature star Daniella Vega the
first openly transgender woman to
present at the Oscars was initially
hired as a script consultant on the
project but was ultimately offered the
lead role despite having no prior
experience as an actress and she turned
in a great performance in a film that
critics say handles its timely sensitive
subject matter with care
another essential LGBTQ film from our
list is 2018 certified fresh love Simon
the first mainstream studio released
teen rom-com with a gay lead character
directed by greg berlanti who's a
driving force behind CW shows like
Riverdale the flash and Batwoman this
fresh take on the coming-of-age story
follows seventeen-year-old Simon who is
yet to tell his family and friends that
he's gay the film which by the way has a
spin-off series called love Victor
that's headed to Hulu this month stars
Jennifer Garner and Josh Duhamel as
parental figures supporting a great
young cast and includes Nick Robinson
Kathryn Langford and Kenan Lonsdale who
was actually inspired to publicly come
out after his involvement in the film
I'm done living in a world where I don't
get to be Who I am
I deserve a great love story next on our
list is the 2017 Netflix documentary the
death and life of Marsha P Johnson about
the black trans activist who played a
pivotal role in the Stonewall riots in
1969 and went on to help form the
world's first trans rights organization
laying the groundwork for what is now
pride using archival interviews with
johnson and new interviews with
Johnson's family friends and fellow
activists this film uses the belated
investigation into Johnson's 1992 death
as the framework for a sobering look on
the ongoing battle for equal rights and
finally we come to 2019 certified fresh
portrait of a lady on fire which is
number two behind moonlight on our best
LGBTQ movies of all time list this
period piece set in France and 1760s
about a female artist commissioned to
paint the wedding portrait of a young
woman who's just left the convent and
the relationship that they form along
with highlighting the timeless ongoing
LGBTQ struggle this film is also pro
feminist as it features only a handful
of short dialogue lines spoken by men
and critics say it finds stirring
thought-provoking drama within a
powerfully acted bromance so if it isn't
the first time boy
cool alright friends it's time for us to
kick it over to you now what are some
LGBTQ films that you think are essential
for people to check out let us know in
the comments section and if you want to
check out our full list head on over to
Ron Tomatoes calm and check out our
rainbow tomatoes hub and if you haven't
already join our fan group on Facebook
now is a great time to connect with us
and keep this conversation going and if
you don't want to miss out on any future
episodes of this show be sure to hit
that subscribe button and notification
bell and as always thank you guys for
watching to catch up i'm ass Prez and
happy Pride Month
[Music]
you